hello and welcome back to the shaky side
the show so in this video I thought I'd
do something a bit different and gives
me advice and so these are my top tips
for making the most out of the summer
lab project so I have been fortunate
enough over the past two summers to have
undertaken some lab experience in two
different labs and so these are provided
me with so much experience and knowledge
that literally was invaluable to doing
my undergrad master's research projects
and hopefully when I stopped my PhD so
Shell's helped all my supervisors so far
but doing a research summer Research
Projects can seem daunting especially if
it's your first you have new people new
methods new places new challenges new
rules but no matter how they go there
are ways that you can make the most out
of your time there so in this video I
will break down my top tips for making
the most out of your lab projects
these tips are also applicable to non
sum of products but congrats that this
is your first summer project they can be
challenging to get and she a really
great initiative and so I hate pills
goes well so here are some tips to help
you make the most out of your summer
project so let's start with tip number
one be prepared so most summer projects
are typically between 8 to 12 weeks now
while this might seem like a long time
in silence this is actually quite short
to ensure you can crack quite some of
your hands-on research in your first
week make sure you come prepared with
background knowledge to your project you
may be joining a project at various
stages and may be just beginning testing
the waters near the end wrapping up or
lost somewhere in the middle but
regardless of the stage there will
always be literature for you to read up
on these include knowing what is out
there regarding your projects already
and getting familiar with the main
proteins cell types pathways you'll be
working on etc so read a few papers by
lab numbers check out some of a few
people's or nature of science so reach
all you need it's watched videos like
this one I guess or watch this out there
it could be prepared some from headings
and if you haven't seen the film and
think I'm crazy
see the film alright sit sit
number two you never feel afraid of
asking for help now this tip extends
beyond being on a lab environment and
they seem like a trivial point but it
always needs to be reminded we don't
know everything and if you are uncertain
you should never feel afraid to ask for
help
plus you're the summer student it's
expected that you will need the guidance
and it is better to ask now when you're
a young and lacking experience compared
to when you've been in research lab for
a couple of years or even more and you
should probably know the answer by that
stage so exploit the power that is your
inexperience like if someone asks me for
help and I can actually help them I feel
pretty good about myself but also
flattered that they considered me as the
helper in the first place of course you
have to realize that eventually you need
to be independent and to trust yourself
so don't over ask if you really have
asked that question before or asked a
similar question
this could become annoying so try and
avoid this by making good notes in your
lab book and taking some independence
oh righty you see tip number three talk
to your supervisor set the rules uh-huh
right say everyone learns in different
ways you may be the first students your
supervisor has had or you could be them
at the necks of money if the latter is
the case don't feel like you have to
compare yourself with previous students
you all have different backgrounds and
learn in different ways for doing
different projects you may feel
particularly this way if there was a lot
of competition for your placement like
an expectation that you must be amazing
but honestly everyone in the lab knows
exactly what it feels like to be the
inexperienced one I'm will probably feel
more comfortable around you if you're a
human just like them and make mistakes
but back to my tip I have a chat with
your supervisor either prior or during
your first few days to discuss the aims
field project so you know decently names
of the projects itself weekly aims but
also the aims of like well you want to
get out of the project yourself it is
also important to discuss how you want
to learn as a general guide a method
that works for many is to watch first do
it under observation and then to do it
alone
you only really ever learn by day
and as a lot of lab science is about
mastering the technique which only comes
from practice making sure you have a lab
work so that you can write things down
the more detailed the better if you
aren't given one inquire if not just
bring your own eight pads and buy
detailed I mean as much of everything
like little sketches to remind you what
items are located or like how to do
protocol then worried about using up
space your that's like a maximum of 12
leaves you're unlikely to elaborate on
that time okay so it's at number four
treats each setback as a learning
experience and ignored this little miss
upper so science can be slow to be
honest I never really had high hopes for
my experimental data mainly because I
think I liked self confidence and my
experimental setup and accuracy but the
point is that everything could work
mistakes will happen in fact important
life lesson if your guarantee fail fell
fast that way you can move on to
something different the worst case is
when the results are uncertain there
could be something worth following but
the data is just isn't conclusive like
the replica errors are too large and say
the experiment needs are pleasing which
takes time but I guess you know you have
to try and practice more eh
all right tip number five mix and /
packs and gloves so one thing I don't
think I really appreciate it when I
start out in the lab is the importance
of mixing and the patent so unless
you're literally al crossing water give
everything a good mix or full text if
necessary before the patent you may
think that juice a Brownian motion and
putting whatever that the solution is
well mixed but oh boy it will make all
the difference and especially important
if you have solutions of proteins DNA
RNA buffer mixes that have been frozen
and thoughts here mixing is essential
for replicas you need consistency hence
a homogenous solution secondly be sure
that you have a patent the crop volume
using the tips that are big enough the
riper parts and be worried that you
aren't for putting out
gloves you will most likely need to take
your gloves off a lot of opening doors
there's may differ to undergrad
practicals where everything goes on the
bench in front of you so get used to
removing your gloves in a way such that
you can reuse them again tip number six
filling gaps network and explore
likelihood is you have sporadic and
foods throughout your day during
incubation Center affiliations Thor in a
cetera where you will recite from your
bench try and fill this time with
something productive
I'm restrained from using social media
center network you may be the youngest
there may be new other summer students
but there will be people that you can
talk to you ask them about that research
people love talking about their research
I'm asked them what they enjoy about the
work their top tips for choosing a lab
tara Gretz and all their suggestions you
know ask people for advice people have
different opinions and different
perspectives and so it's just good to
talk to different people
I mean secondly explore other seminars
that you can attend sports clubs after
well that you can go to papers that you
should be reading notes to make in your
lab book making use of those 10 to 15
minute gaps will make relaxing and
watching Netflix way more rewarding in
the evening trust me
okay now tip number seven invest in your
project at the end of your project
you'll probably have to present to the
rest of the lab what you've been up to
you get out what you put in so take the
time to read the literature and they'll
just like the start but during your
project this will best enable you to
come up with hypotheses to fit your
results suggest new experiments and to
apply a cool methods you read in a
different paper it's your in work also
suggest potential future experiments to
the lab about tip number eight don't
burn outs during your projects make sure
you take breaks I'm sure that you stay
hydrated establish what your working
hours are in a lab you are likely to be
allowed in a lab alone so this could
place you on a time schedule from around
8:30 a.m. to around 7 p.m. it will
likely depends on the lab and your
supervisor but make sure you are happy
with your hours and don't feel like
you're being
to Salem with anyone's problems can only
get solved after knowing about if you
were prefer to work later and finish
later say say or faceoff now this may
seem like a lot of effort a kin and
while it is starting out the lab is a
steep learning curve and yes it can be
tough
you may feel uncomfortable at times
which may make it an enjoyable and
stressful at moments but the enjoyment
and satisfaction and these will come
give it time and once you have
confidence using the equipment whether
by the end of your summer projects or in
subsequent projects you can focus more
on the science and designing the best
experiments to answer your biological
questions when your project finishes be
sure to thank your supervisor and the
lab and give them a small gift in a car
to say thank you and make sure you stay
in touch this is diesel for getting
references in the future finding out how
your project progresses and for
maintaining contacts and friends in the
fields that hopefully you'll decide to
join so yeah I hope you found these tips
useful I've put a summary of all the
different tips here and if you're
interested in finding out more about
what I got up to during my two summer
projects I put a link to the description
to both these different projects so yeah
check this out if you want to bob waste
yet thanks for listening and have fun of
your projects